all right so glad wait for version
pretty grow I grew up in Kansas City a
little town called Coffeeville okay tell
me about your childhood you grew up with
both parents um I grew up with both
parents but they were never together so
it was like one weekend with my mom and
one weekend with my dad go back and
forth okay with a good wage for you when
they got first I was a little little kid
I was not even a year old yet I don't
think when they got the horse and how
was he childhood I had a good childhood
he's fine yeah you got along with your
mom and dad what age were you when you
left Kansas um well things were kind of
weird I lived in New York for a lot of
my childhood so from like the time I was
like born really to like six I was
living in New York and then from 6 to 19
as when I was living in Kansas okay for
about a year I lived in Oklahoma then
went back to Kansas and how long you
been in the lead up industry about a
week a week so you're brand-new
brand-new yeah yeah what attracted you
to it something I've always wanted to do
I'm a very open person about my
sexuality
and it looked really fun honestly like
you know just to be able to kind of be
myself and do things that I enjoy and
being an environment where it's okay to
like those things where I grow up it's
like everyone's very conservative and
stuff so people didn't really like me
too much they thought I was a bad person
because I was you know adventurous or
like I wore certain clothes that they
didn't like to see people in so being in
the industry allows me to explore
aspects of myself without having a
negative stigma as much what is it about
your personality that kind of like led
you to that do you think something you
just naturally more free with your
sexuality yeah I think they offer you're
always that way you're young yes I'll
hold you 21 21 yeah I've always been
kind of open about it and I've always
liked trying new things I'm someone
who's not scared to try anything new and
I'll do anything to see if I like it or
not so it's the same way with like try
anything sexually I've never you know
shied away from anything you know I've
got to try it to see if I enjoy it and
it's just always been that way ever
since I was like 12 13 is when I
like having sex and like exploring that
aspect of my life so I just you know
from a young age I kind of gained
experience doing certain things I've
always had that knowledge do you parents
know you're doing it they don't know no
so does that do any of your friends no
or my roommate knows I'm doing it yeah
and he's super supportive of it he
thinks it's cool and he's glad that I'm
like doing something that I enjoy and
finding the time to explore something
for myself did you just move to
California
I'm staying with someone yeah that's
what you're not even told me yeah I'm
not totally moved anywhere yet have you
done your first scene yet yeah I've been
to her house
what was your experience after doing the
first thing it was really nice
everyone's really welcoming and they
make sure to ask you know a whole bunch
of questions about what you're
comfortable with what you aren't
comfortable with and you know a lot of
times they tell you a word to say or an
action to do if you want to take a break
and so it's just
a really safe environment and everyone's
super nice all the time and it's great
because it has a reputation as being
other than answer yeah and it's very
welcoming everyone has you know guided
me like if I have any questions they're
answered and everyone I've worked with
has like giving me tips and told me like
do's and don'ts and just how to be more
comfortable in everything thank you so
much for talking to me hope everything
works out for you thank you thank you